but let's not forget the big one right
now
the big Avenue in the culture wars four
Republicans is of course critical were
Ace Theory critical race Theory which
most of them can't even Define they have
no idea what it actually means but they
hate it
and they're doing everything possible to
make sure this is not taught in schools
even though it's already not taught in
schools
and Florida's Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis became the latest Republican
last week to take aim at this imaginary
foe to conservatism by signing a bill
called the stop woke Act
and the stop woke act prevents schools
here in the State of Florida from
teaching critical race Theory even
though it wasn't a thing that was taught
you can't even hint at in schools now
because this legislation that there was
ever any kind of racism in the United
States justice system which means I
guess no more talking about slavery no
more talking about Jim Crow no more
talking about lots of portions of the
United States uh Constitution
so I don't know what kids are going to
be learning in history classes here in
Florida because it sure as hell isn't
going to be American history anymore
because DeSantis has made it to where if
you find out that your child is being
taught critical race Theory
in public schools here in the State of
Florida you can sue the school district
that's what he's doing you the parent
can now Sue that school district
which gets funding from this
state which DeSantis runs so I I guess
in a way you're suing Ron DeSantis
if your child learns about American
history yeah he didn't really think it's
through because that's not what Ron
DeSantis does he doesn't sit there and
think things through Ron DeSantis is
only thinking about one thing and that's
when is he going to be able to run for
president of the United States
this is just the latest in legislation
signed by Florida's Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis this year about culture War
issues
that's all the man knows how to do this
state is absolutely dying from covid and
most of them are Republicans
62 000 I think were up to deaths in the
State of Florida from covid with Omicron
out there numbers right back going up
again just like they are all over the
country and Ron desantis's biggest
concern is
critical race Theory that's already not
being taught something he doesn't even
Define in the legislation so of course
it's going to open the door for any
right-wing parent to sue a school
district if their kid comes home and
says hey we learned about Martin Luther
King today hey we learned about slavery
today parents can say wonderful I'm
gonna go call my lawyer and we're going
to put an end to this
now it's unlikely that the legislation
obviously is going to hold up in an
actual Court
but by the time we get to that we will
have seen countless lawsuits here in the
State of Florida filed against public
schools
we're going to drain them of resources
which they likely will not be able to
get back
and that's going to put the burden back
on the state
when these school districts even if they
win the lawsuits right they're still
going to have to pay all the legal fees
lawyers ain't cheap folks
and we're putting it on our already
underfunded school districts
so even if they win they're going to pay
tens of thousands of dollars to defend
themselves in court where are we going
to make up that money again
either they're going to have to raise
taxes on Florida residents which we know
Republicans who control the state refuse
to do
uh maybe they'll do it because it's on
regular constituents and of course not
corporations of the wealthy Elite or
we're just going to have to eat the
costs and sacrifice elsewhere in the
schools
there's no good outcome for this is what
I'm getting at here for the State of
Florida and our Public School System
either we end up with even worse
underfunded schools here in the state
or we end up with an entire generation
of children that is completely ignorant
about the Real History of the United
States
neither one of those outcomes are good
they're both very very bad
but that's what Ron DeSantis is doing
because he is now the king of the
Republican culture wars
he's the General on the ground fighting
these wars for them
and he's attacking things that don't
exist and like I said this is not the
first one he's done this year he also
signed the transgender athlete ban
oh no no transgender women
can't play women's sports here in the
State of Florida transgender men however
can still play men's sports
neither of those things are an issue
though neither of those things have
caused problems we have a lot of college
football here in the State of Florida we
have a lot of pro football here in the
state of Florida
three major NFL teams
three major college teams and a lot of
secondary college teams as well and
that's just football alone
and not once has there ever been any
kind of uproar over a transgender man or
transgender woman
attempting to play these Sports and
having some kind of unfair Advantage but
Ron DeSantis knew that he could get his
Republican base riled up about it and of
course distract from the fact that
people are dying in this state left and
right from covid
so it's a two-prong uh victory for him
really he gets the Pander to the worst
people in the state and he gets to
distract from his horrendous handling of
the covid-19 pandemic and again he's
doing a dang good job of it nobody is
fighting the culture wars as hard as Ron
DeSantis and of course what's on the
horizon for us
an abortion ban modeled after the one in
the state of Texas too
I am Farren cousins find me on Twitter
Instagram Facebook at fair and balanced
we will be right back with more on the
David packman show